veulent tout faire c'est vrai c'est la
chose positive qui réclament l'abandon
pas jusque là
tout pareil alors que les mots toit pour
toi ce n'est pas le cas du tout toi tu
étais heureux de faire cette aventure
voilà est pour toi c'est pas du tout une
mascarade
bah en fait faut pas oublier une chose
c'est que ça reste quand même une
aventure humaine qui est énormément
remplie d'émotion donc on peut vite se
faire submerger par l'émotion et on peut
vite se perdre après il ya autre chose
on n'a pas eu le même mariage moi je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé dans leur
mariage comme eux ils savent pas ce qui
s'est passé en iran
chaque mois chaque mariage est différent
à prix fort pour bienne ce jeudi à la
compatibilité la compatibilité mais il
ya aussi le côté humain et le côté
humain fait la validation ou non de se
marier nation sans ça moi je les ai
vécus vraiment à 2000% l'aura aussi en
même si l'issue voilà tous vu hier on
s'est séparés surya aucune animosité
entre nous on s'est toujours soutenu ans
est toujours entre aidez moi j'ai
compris tout s'est ressenti à être un
peu tard elle pas forcément elle a pas
su gérer donc j'en ai combattu pendant
un moment donné mais c'est normal c'est
un monde il est où les coupes ne peuvent
pas marcher assure garder surtout
c'est à tous les couples là il ya quand
même cette coupe soit disant ultra
compatibles a que trois qui alors si on
sait faire ça alors c'est donc avec la
machine
si jamais pour jouer avec le mariage le
mariage ça crée du jeu ça que je suis
d'accord avec les abers médias disent
que dans la vraie vie
guillaume pardon il ya aussi des
histoires at et bien sûr à thème oui il
ya un couple sur deux qui divorcent et
charges il emporte moi je suis d'accord
rapidement s'ils sont de toi parce que
toi d'habitude tu n'aimes pas les
émissions que tu dis de télé réalité va
on est pour le coup dans une émission de
télé réalité qui porte vraiment son nom
pour le coup parce que c'est bien la
réalité qu'on filme et il ya du tout en
tout cas de table un verso du figaro qui
est formidable damien qui me dit les
couples mélina yannick et mines trade
viennent d'annoncer leur séparation sur
les réseaux sociaux grimaud également
donc c'est vrai qu'après y avoir il ya
beaucoup beaucoup williams et leur
sincérité je remet absolument pas en
cause parce que vraiment vous m'avez
tirer les larmes et je trouve formidable
mais en revanche c'est le principe même
de cette fameuse compatibilité
scientifique en amour il n'y a pas de
science et pas de mathématiques n'y a
pas de lampe à petit billy taylor fait
pas une question de facilité c'est juste
un moment donné quand on arrive les
jours des castings ou des rencontres
avec les experts on a quand même un
panel énorme de question on a beaucoup
de réponses on a beaucoup de choses à
raconter sur notre vie donc si on part
du principe que moi j'ai répondu
correctement que la personne avec qui on
m'a mis une compatibilité répond
correctement et sincère forcément on est
sincèrement c'est là où je rejoins non
géraldine pas ce qu'il allait dire
madame paillé c'est là où je rejoins
géraldine un moment donné le match et là
on fait ce qu'elle a vu les classes de
vos réponses mais comme dans un casting
je lui c'est un casting en fait et on
s'est dit c'est 2 ans voit tout de suite
avec de l'engrais très même ensemble
avec l'oreille on le voit tout de suite
la compatibilité reçurent en deux
secondes on rentre dans les directs mois
en 2009 de direct sur moi la seule chose
après effectivement ou la prod peut
intervenir c'est sur des choses qui nous
demande qu'est ce qu'on veut moi j'ai
demandé un caprice et ça y va boucler
rejeter les boîtiers noirs un kebab
vous demandez un tournant qu'a pris j'ai
demandé un camion dit qu'est ce que tu
veux moi je suis comme vous fan de
enrico macias j'ai dit je le corps l'éco
mafia c'est bien moi viennent chanter
amant marié jeu le mendiant de l'amour
ils m'ont dit ça va être compliqué la
directrice de rappeler christ m'appelle
me dit on peut pas mais il va te faire
une vidéo pour te faire un coupable et
félicitations sauf que le jour où il a
fait la vidéo c'est un vendredi c'était
shabbat donc non sur ses vraies clés moi
je voulais dire c'est de l'amour à la
tête chaîne chance car il y en a mais
des m'amuser voilà les mots je suis
chemin voilà c'est la seule chose qu'on
avait demandé en rigolant mais voilà
dans l'est c'est quoi le fait que la
mener un jour et demi qu'on voit sur la
tête de ma mère gilles ce week end au
téléphone en plus ouais mais il était en
concert aussi après marie à nouveau du
coup et alors qu'on est au top
ce gap il ya plein de gens là qui me
disent les trois célibataires on n'y
croit pas on a envie de se positionner
il ya plein de gens qui aujourd'hui je
me concentre beaucoup sur je profite de
cette image de surfer un peu pour les
associations d'ailleurs j'étais chez
sofiane chez solaris au soir il est venu
avec toi exactement je connais bien là
donc je fais un bisou jean pierre
mireault théo c était au nid d'amour
d'amour n'ont pour l'instant non je me
suis reconcentré sur mes proches ma mère
ma soeur
ah oui et puis sur le boulot sur sur des
choses essentielles de la vie et puis il
ya trois ans à redescendre un peu
vraiment énergie morale maire doit
revoir est tu dois avoir beaucoup de
sollicitations c'est vrai que ta mère
était formidable tu dois beaucoup de
sollicitations
les procès des détresses oui oui oui je
le dis mais que tu te méfies mal pour
l'instant ouais c'est ça c'est parce
qu'en fait la médiatisation c'est vrai
c'est ça c'est quelque chose de très
nouveau pour nous et à gérer c'est pas
c'est pas forcément ceinture c'est leur
gardien aujourd'hui il a pété un câble
ça va regarder c'est bien chaud
c'est le problème il fallut célibataires
eux
disons que je vois quelqu'un que j'aime
bien mais voyez passer ou non je vais
jeter l'émoi je vous verrai grave ouais
je trouve que vous iriez vous avez une
grave en soi mais vous êtes très beau
merci beauty et marie pierre et brique
aussi vous voulez ce n'était pas un
penalty fanni peut donc on n'est pas au
bar expliqué agnel est un clip de vidéos
c'est votre cas c'est votre style ah oui
totalement et complètement
et alors non non je vous trouve très
ferme en mai après voilà vous vous
cherchez quelqu'un de simple et je crois
que suis un petit peu trop sauvage voit
un petit peu trop bas du tout du tout
ils cherchent l'amour tout simplement et
c'est la définition de la simplicité
pour vous cet automne dans la simplicité
et la sophistication suprême
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais j'ai pas dis vous êtes un peu
l'asean célibataire si mais si vous
deviez choisir entre les trois garçons
lequel serait le plus beau style tout de
suite voilà marié au premier regard vous
pourquoi ce que vous me semblez plus
sincères et ya l'air plus sérieux non
toi si t'es pas parce qu'il ya eu une
licence est si parfaite jeu parce qu'ils
sont dits petits sur leur physique aussi
les gérer son stress et donc les mots
mais je suis pas bien physiquement c'est
ce que tu veux mais tu vois pas mais bon
c'est vraiment les beaux gosses quoi
jouons-nous à la voir mon jeu vraiment
ça voilà c'est ça ce qu'on pense de nous
c'est qu'on joue systématiquement notre
physique est tous assez sympa du tout
parce que les fouilles des beaux mais
c'est pas exprès c'est ça en fait non
rétabli la vérité
oui on les voit ils sont beaux ils ont
des abdos nous on n'en a pas moins ses
joues tu dis ça pour la can c'est bruce
willis a fait craquer sur clément
janequin est indéniable mais c'est cette
façon et je veux dire j'ai beaucoup de
goût il est bon pas pour continuer comme
ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est sûr d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
me passer bon jour mais si on place
alain yannick fred et nous interdire
parce que c'est cool ça peut être
compliqué car à bord mais où le vent me
pousse et heureux d'avoir fait la
voiture quand même oui moi je suis
heureux bien sûr qu'on est heureux
enfin moi je peux avoir moi je fais
quatre fois qu'ils viennent à tpb bien
sûr qu'ils sont je suis très heureux
c'est vrai en plus pour rejoindre
clément humainement parlant et tout ce
qu'on a pu vivre à travers cette
expérience c'est vrai que c'est
exceptionnel c'est magnifique c'est des
souvenirs inoubliables tout au long de
notre vie maintenant c'est plus le trait
en interne
voilà les mariages sont différents les
compatibilités sont différentes aussi
les personnes sont différentes il faut
de tout pour faire un monde il faut de
tout pour faire marié au premier regard
alors y'a bouder qui me dit il confiant
vous êtes des vrais beaux gosses et il
sait de quoi il parle et vous vous aussi
mais vous n'en avez vous aussi vous êtes
heureux ah oui bon c'est que moi je vous
le dirai quand vous aurez trouvé l'amour
ben voilà c'est quoi votre style j'ai
pas de style c'est avant tout c'est pas
un shilling une femme les cheveux
j'adore les longs cheveux
ah ouais ouais bah là franchement alors
que la belle mère tous vous regardez
compromis moi c'est moi le regard way le
rosaire pour leur guerre le sourire ça
en dit long sur l'âme de la personne
c'est vrai moi même très longue attente
je
c'est précisé cellulaire un prêt l'été
ouais c'est ça ouais t'as l'air elle
avait un bon burger et un beau sourire
et non ses neuf est une belle personne
pourtant si on parle que d'eux que du
physique non le physique c'est ça fait
pas tout et secondaire c'est sale c'est
vous regarder passer en premier parce
que je regarde en premier chez une femme
oui oui son âme de notre gueule
longtemps très longtemps